As they're talking,
Marla notices that Dr.
Johnson is recording what they say on
a new tablet computer and asks about it.
He explains that he recently
installed an electronic medical
records system as part
of a federal program.
He goes on to explain that he'll be able
to use it to send an electronic record
of her care to Dr.
Jones, so she will have it well
before Marla's scheduled visit.
Marla is impressed.
She doesn't want to remind Dr. Johnson,
but she remembers that when she first
visited him, he didn't have her records,
and she ended up having some blood tests
she had already had in a prior
visit to one of her other doctors.
Marla doesn't like needles, so
she's glad this won't happen again.